so yes piers i have a question james
sanders thank you so much for joining us
always a pleasure
peters morgan has a question for you how
can boris johnson stay in office tonight
i'm happy to answer questions from you
my wife would divorce me if i took
questions from piers morgan let me let
me put my cards on the table i've always
supported trans rights to fairness and
equality and i mean that sincerely i
want everyone
bro well you can say bro and that's fine
you're entitled to it's an uncensored
show and you've just proven it but let
me just say to you i always
wasn't your profile picture
identified penguin congratulations on
the holy one all right thank you very
much thank you very much thank you very
much we appreciate it
okay thank you okay let's go that was a
great interview yeah that's fine thank
you very much i really appreciate it
turn the camera off
stanley it's great to see you as always
an effervescent presence and you are a
cheater i've got to tell you piers you
know you lured me in here it was a bit
like cecil the lion
there's nothing wrong with defending
your son by the way and we got to talk
about trophy hunting and your book and i
showed you doing a handstand the world's
looking for stanley oh thank you peers
good to see you see you all folks
tell boris to come in soon no honesty no
objectivity no openness he has trashed
every single one of the standards in
public life and peers i've got to tell
you i still was coming to talk to you
because you're quite a serious person
i'm i've got sherwood on pause
downstairs take douglas murray take him
back and put him in his 55 tufton street
pin and i'll see you later all the best
thank you alistair campbell
lots of love to aaron thanks for joining
us
thanks very much for joining us we have
sadly lost allison campbell i would
support you the problem i have with your
tactics is you put me off supporting you
you don't bring me to your protest i
don't think i want to join these guys
they're making a great point i just look
at this poor woman and think why have
you done that to her and her kid i look
at these terrible stories of a woman
left paralyzed because you lot were
lying in front of a car it's like why do
that there are other ways to protest
because you're not listening to what
i've just said you're not emotionally
connecting to the fact that what i've
just said to you is one billion actually
you're not listening to what i'm saying
no i am but what i'm saying and we're in
what you're not hearing is i'm agreeing
with your calls with the campaign
i just don't agree with the tactics i
want you to concede but i don't agree
with government criminality
i have issues about safety for women i
have issues about other areas of women's
rights do you understand whatever
do you understand and appreciate what
all these dog whistles and talking
points they're not dog whistles and
talking points
they are legitimate areas of concern you
can't just call everyone who disagrees
with you
please
if you keep swearing i'll have to kill
you you can go and have a look at their
websites you can have a look at their
twitters
like they are transphobic but i am
telling you was kicked out i just i just
said to you all right you're going to
have women's place uk if you don't want
to have a civilized conversation with me
okay look look i'm trying to give you a
chance i've explained my position
what is your problem with my position
i don't really know i'm gonna leave the
interview now i kind of only came on
here because i thought it would be kind
of funny um but i want to say you're and
you're a fan
all right well i apologize again to all
uh viewers who are listening to that uh
unfortunately a complete idiot was the
last time you went to university peers
uh the last time you were a student i
was a student when i was 19. oh how old
are you that's a long time ago that was
a long hard time
could i say that are you being aged yeah
i'm just saying wow that's a fact it was
a long time ago
does he think he's does he think he's
now britain's comical ally
yeah sorry i i've got peers in in
the only person that's comical here is
this thing you should get two well if
you can hear me if you can hear me
if you can hear me i love kate i will
answer the case but i'm not going to
answer to you i think it's very very bad
tv i don't need to be disrespectful okay
really okay let me tell you what i think
of you
twerk
i think you're very bad tv you're the
comical ally of british politics
everyone's laughing at you so if i i
suggest you take a little michael's
happiness
i think unfortunately we've uh lost our
opportunity to talk to james here but
james thank you thank you so much let me
help you unclip that uh which is in your
pocket there we go i didn't mean to be
rude
quite all right but please look one of
the one of the big things there
one of the biggest
thank you
[Music]